it's clearly been prepared by jordan van
furis look at his clock time he's gained
more than a minute from when he started
the game and also look at the speed he's
continuing this idea was revealed
recently by fabiano caruana
in an online game and white has actually
sacrificed a porn that's why the
evaluation buys on black side that's why
it says plus one point something for
black and look at white's king though
it's castle on the queen side black's
king's castle in king's side opposite
side castling only means one thing
all-out attack trouble exactly chaos and
uh now look at this last move by jordan
van furist he's almost moving without
using his hand
you can see that he's just super relaxed
he's studied this before maybe even with
the likes of magnus carson and uh now
the idea is clear white is going to
throw his g pawn up the board in front
of that white rook and he's just going
to go for the black king it's all or
nothing now it's that type of chess from
white he's a pawn down long term he's
simply lost but he's going all out on
the attack yeah and this type of
position is so disconcerting for david
navarro because it's a very sharp
position that's the first thing second
thing jordan is just blitzing out the
moves so he's in his preparation and the
question is do you play the most natural
move and this move that david navarro
has played is not the most natural move
it would have been way more natural just
to stop that pawn from advancing and uh
here it comes
it's a a porn storm that pawn the g pawn
is about to march one square forward and
start opening some lines and remember
when you are attacking the king you want
to open up those lines
why because you want to have open
area so that the pieces can hop in and
create those mating threats
in all honesty i would be absolutely
terrified here's black this is
i mean i love chess i've been playing
for uh 25 years but
this would be one of the most scary
opening positions i would have ever
faced and i can't imagine navarro i mean
his he looks super calm but
he's facing not just jordan but jordan's
computer jordan's coaches everyone who's
studied this position with jordan before
and also it's the type of position where
you could just get mated as black in the
next five moves white's pawn that has
just moved if it moves one square
further up the white rook will open and
it's just checkmate the black king is
going to be defenseless and um i saw
this game
that caruana won recently one of the
world's best players and it just
happened like that he won in five ten
moves from this position pretty much
just by going for that black king and if
you look at black's king it doesn't have
too many defenders around it the knight
is nearby but if the knight has to fight
against the white queen the white rooks
there's no chance so the evaluation bar
might say it's roughly level but that's
with perfect defense from black and
white's attacking plan is so
straightforward
he's just going to throw everything
towards that black king there's no way
that this position is level david
i mean just forget the bar
whatever when the king's on the opposite
side of the board and the queens are
still on and the rooks are still on no
no no this is not equal at all i mean
you can just look at david on the camera
you know he's shaking his head he's even
kind of is he laughing great missing i
can't quite make it out he's
uncomfortable and uh i've been
on the receiving end on this kind of
pawn structure because of a line that i
play in the karakan and i can tell you
it is so scary
and that pawn is one square away from
opening up a line and it's
the rooks the white rooks are bearing
down uh towards black's king and the
white queen is easily
going to be able to switch sides and
look the the at the king it's it's
terrifying
and uh
but the good news is
we are not the ones playing with the
black horses
we are just spectators and we can just
sit there and enjoy the game and but
what would you do what would i do that's
not that's not something we need to
concern ourselves with because it looks
terrible i honestly don't know i would
try the f pawn one step but
i was thinking the f pawn as well but
unfortunately
it's on the same the king is on the same
line as the bishop
and this would mean that the deep one
could move one square forward take a
pawn and it would be check
and uh
maybe giving back a pawn is the best way
at least now temporarily you've
prevented white from opening up this
line as we mentioned towards the white
king you gain some time as black by
hitting the white bishop i like it yeah
okay but also the the queen will be a
bit more hampered right
because you move the pawn and blocking
the queen
a little bit yeah you've blocked the
queen and uh if white has to spend a
move retreating this bishop then at
least you have a little bit of breathing
space for example if the bishop drops
back here okay black has a few moves you
could capture with the knight and at
least you've survived if white wants to
just completely blow open the g-file and
push this pawn forward it will come at
the cost of a knight
at least now you're defending everything
you have closed this line temporarily
and i don't think white has enough uh in
order to sacrifice here i think
maybe white can try this but pushing a
pawn forward but at least you have
something to cling on to black has an
extra knight um i think this might be
the best chance at least in practical
terms as you mentioned like just pushing
this pawn forward otherwise i mean if
you get greedy if you take a pawn in the
center first i think white might even
just ignore his bishop and just blow
open the position uh pushing this pawn
and it's all about this rook if it can
break through to the black king it might
be checkmate shortly
and uh yeah it's just that type of
position this is a monster threat
pushing forward
and it needs to be stopped and it's used
four minutes four and a half minutes
yeah i think it's a psychological kind
of shock as well of i mean this is one
e4 e5
for black it's supposed to be the most
solid opening in chess and after 15
moves you're facing
such a scary attack yeah well but at
least david navarro he's been on a roll
he's won uh three out of the five last
games and uh he is
in um oh we have the move we have the
millions here that's suggested by kura
yeah fantastic all right i'm just going
to quickly go through the standings so
these are the standings before round 11.
liam leah's still in first place magnus
carlson in second place and the player
is now fighting intensely to be inside
top eight we have dingley ren just about
inside david navarro as well he is in
that crucial eighth place yodenfun
forest in that sixth place so this is an
important
game between these two they are lurking
around that crucial eighth place vedic
and pragnanda just outside fighting to
get in so is eric hansen
wow
yeah but still you know he did my
suggestion but the bar swearing the
opposite so i'm not sure
okay but the computer is really
materialistic so uh sometimes you
you know you've got to look at the
position from a practical human sense
and
and one of the things about computers
especially when you have an engine such
as this and maybe not with the really
really great engines is that they only
calculate up to a certain move and
they're just like yeah it's it's okay 10
moves ahead
but on the 11th move it probably isn't
okay
so it depends on the depth the super
super computers
they think in a different way yeah they
have deeper horizons for example and um
actually now ai has got involved with
chess so alpha zero which is maybe the
most famous ai program um it started
beating uh the kind of strongest human
programmed uh computer and that doesn't
actually work in plus one plus two the
ai programs work in percentages they
they say if they play themselves a
hundred times in this position they
would win maybe 65
and stuff like that and i was going to
say
without this move maybe black would have
been okay according to man-made
computers but i think ai uh engines they
would have seen that okay white
would have had 65 chance of winning with
an attack or maybe an 80 uh 80 chance of
winning with an immediate attack at
least now
maybe white will win maybe white can
just grab a pawn back and the game will
go on a long time but in human terms
it's better to just survive the next
five ten moves and uh take the fight
later
to later in the game and look at this
also it's made jordan think
so maybe not the top computer move
according to some engines but in
practical terms and human terms it's by
far i think the best movement yeah well
spotted because the number one priority
was to stop white opening up this g-file
and uh david you mentioned uh ai and
computers and i do have to share with
you some selfies because the next one is
so cool dwayne tiller is watching the
charity cup in the metaverse
how cool is that whoa
i've
never seen anything like that i've heard
a lot about the metaverse but yeah this
is so awesome and
okay and uh he didn't capture the pawn
instead he introduced a knight into the
center
nice
nice interesting move from uh jordan
and made after a couple of minutes
thinking and that's what might happen i
mean the evaluation bus swinging back to
black side black is a pawn up after all
and uh i just think jordan's influence
uh
working with someone like daniel dubov
just wanting to be a pawn down in many
positions not giving any time
not wasting a move capturing a pawn back
i think that's in general a good thing
for his chest but here
the white knight yes it looks good it
does feel like it's going in the wrong
direction slightly though and anywhere
that white knight wants to jump into
will just get captured by black's bishop
so okay interesting move i guess he
wants to maybe free up the white f pawn
to step forward so maybe the white f
pawn will step forward and then the
white g pawn it's it's a bit slower
though than it previously was
the attack for jordan forest
and uh navarro will be much happier now
that jordan did spend a couple of
minutes on that move he knows he's no
longer maybe facing pure homework and uh
purely the computer suggestions does he
have any sneaky ideas as well for
instance just because i saw it you know
knight takes pawn
and look maybe it looks like it could be
an active move
maybe he has the idea of playing
knight takes porn himself
interesting so we always talk about
looking for checks and captures first
the idea is that now you've opened up
the white queen so after bishop takes
knight a recapture you can actually
recapture with your queen with a double
attack and uh still very complicated
here it's not clear what would happen
for example if black just threw the king
out the way and now white's queen is
offside might be some nazi checks a
counter-attack now against the white
king but uh either way that is maybe one
idea that slightly scares the opponent
it's the type of thing you at least make
your opponent burn time calculating but
in the current position david navarro
did not feel brave enough to capture
this pawn instead he blocked things up
so he's trying to now at least lock in
this bishop this bishop no longer has a
direct path to the black king and also
gaining some time against the white
knight
as mentioned the white knight if it
jumps forward it wants to jump forward
of course with a fork double attack and
now it will just get traded off for
black's bishop and suddenly yes this is
a far advanced pawn but white's bishop
is blunted and black now can continue
gaining time and suddenly white's attack
has lost all its momentum so i don't
think white wants to see any trades i
think in this position we'll see the
knight retreat if anything if jordan's
feeling really ambitious maybe we'll see
him throw pawns on the board but i think
he has to take a time out to save his
knight and he has done he steps it back
so still jordan's idea is to push this
pawn forward and then push the pawn next
to it it's still about opening up lines
for the rook just takes a lot longer now
and meanwhile black has a couple of
moves to counter-attack and he starts
that by moving his rook across he's
trying the pawn storm on his flank and
it's very much about going for the
opponent's kings and whose attack will
be quicker and this is definitely the
type of position where we should ignore
the evaluation bar because it's not yeah
it's so irrational this type of position
it's hard for a human to handle
yeah i mean i just wonder about uh
david's last move because i thought
maybe it might be too slow it might feel
slow it does feel slow right and i
thought maybe it might have been worth
just giving up a pawn instead of
preparing this push just open up that
line anyhow it comes at the cost of the
pawn but you do get an open line for
your rook and you gain a bit of time
against white's bishop in the process so
yeah that would have been really
interesting ivanka
and uh meanwhile yeah this move yes it
prepares oops sorry it prepares this
pawn push but
even if that happens i think if white
now pushes this pawn forward even if
this happens white's bishop actually
finds maybe even better diagonal anyway
so okay let's see how the players react
who is going to be quicker in this race
of attacks
good question
all right
jordan from forest and david navarro
both inside top eight but uh they're not
uh safe to qualify for the knockout
stage tomorrow will be the final day of
preliminaries and devon mri almost
smiling when jordan makes that bishop
move
yeah i think he's just smiling because
he's being surprised on every turn
i'm surprised as well that bishop it was
about to get attacked but he retreated
it anyway and
maybe just doing it in a different order
to the one we assumed
it's kind of a preemptive strike there
and white's bishop does indeed find this
long diagonal this new diagonal that i
was uh mentioning
white does have an idea a sneaky idea
now of lifting the white queen up one
square lining it up with its bishop and
then creeping in to deliver some nasty
checks to the black king if you look at
this light light square diagonal the
white bishop is sitting on some holes
there in black's camp
what's your game yeah what a game it's
uh this is what we love there's nothing
more exciting in chess than opposite
side castling because then it always
ends up in chaos some mutual attacks
and okay look at this navara stopping
the white queen from stepping up one
square onto the light square diagonal
and uh now jordan look at this
evaluation bar just yoyoing can't make
its mind up
it certainly can't i would be tempted if
i would just vary jordan just uh
continue with the plan
you know they have that saying in chess
the the person that strikes first
and then it continues and i've forgotten
the rest of it uh i don't know that
phrase
well something about the person who
strikes first is has the most thirst
yeah it doesn't quite go like that
we'll often uh guess in the first blow
right
so it's not right first is not the worst
it's not the worst no it's not a rhyme
it wasn't a rhyme but basically you
should be the one we only do right
yeah remember we only do rhymes my bad
my bad but you know the general rule is
you should be the one who strikes first
because you've got to be the one that uh
has the momentum because
then you know if if you land the blow
you open up a line chances are that uh
here he goes here he goes pawn pushes
and uh as david's highlighted several
times what his plan is just to pick up
gary the g pawn move it up one square
and activate the rooks
and it's it's consistent right and in
general interests you can't just change
your mind on every turn kind of start
one plan then switch to another plan
then go back to another plan you just
have to be consistent they do say that
uh having a bad plan is better than
having no plan at all so uh here whether
or not it works i think this is a good
idea from uh uh jordan ramforis just
throwing all the pawns towards black
it's also scary remember psychology is
so important and nevarra also quite a
lot lower on the clock five minutes down
compared to jordan it's scary to face
all of the pawns rolling towards your
king and meanwhile black's pawns
yes they're quite far advanced as well
on the other side but they lack pieces
backing them up and they still take a
while themselves to open up lines and
you mentioned uh gary the g poem ivanka
do you have names for the pieces here
no actually not no i don't know
you know like pet names yeah like harry
the h paul and we also have alice the a
pawn
and i guess for kids
i mean for your four-year-old that's an
interesting way to learn yeah maybe
that's good uh playgrounds yeah yeah
yeah try to
be careful be careful with that because
i i once was teaching a very young boy
and i said you know he said to me well
why does it have to be harry the h why
is that fine name it what you want and
he goes lucifer
i was like
[Laughter]
that's the fun thing about kids the
creativity right we should maybe stick
to the rhymes where like doubled pawns
or troubled pawns actually something
that we learned from here
names can be tricky yeah uh but yeah
talking of tricky this position look at
this black's pawns continuing to advance
towards the white king white's pawns
advancing towards the black king and uh
jordan didn't even flinch he just
ignored black's attack he's going all
out uh on the king's side and oh wow the
pawns continue advancing the evaluation
bar might say it's level but this is
anything but level this one is going to
end up with a decisive result surely wow
i think a draw is by far the least
likely now i didn't expect david to be
so bold
i mean i really thought that maybe he'd
move his knight in and try to create
some defensive uh
possibilities around along the seventh
row but this is brave stuff i mean is he
going to continue or is he
talking of bold white has just
sacrificed a piece white's bishop now
can just be captured by a pawn and
the black king it's really there we go
the bishop had to be eliminated the
bishop was actually a good attacker on
this diagonal and yeah the black king is
just fending for itself jordan look how
he's leaning in his instincts tell him
there's a checkmate for example starting
with white's rook going up and capturing
the pawn in front of the black king but
at least for now the black king can hide
in the corner and we have to investigate
right okay definitely because uh this
one i mean this one is just fire on the
board and uh in this position the reason
this bishop was captured rather than
just than this pawn it looks like
black's about to make a new queen it's
actually unstoppable making a new queen
on the next move but unfortunately after
rook takes pawn check uh the king hiding
in the corner now we see why the bishop
had to be eliminated the bishop actually
supports this check from afar so the
king would be forced back uh to a square
where it's vulnerable so the bishop had
to be eliminated and it was and now
jordan instead of taking the pawn with
the rook which would have actually been
maybe a mistake because now there's no
way to continue checking the black king
instead he captured this pawn with his
own pawn so now first of all big big
threat of winning a rook for free and
making a new queen in the process but a
secondary threat for example if the rook
moves and i think it must
of just pushing your pawns quietly and
trying to deliver checkmate to this king
with some pawns at the very minimum
trying to make a new queen and uh this
one is still going to be mightily scary
for black maybe you can stop it either
by
blocking with your king in this position
planting the king on the edge of the
board or maybe more likely by putting
your bishop on this square just keeping
an
eye on the pawn advance but still
super scary if the white queen can
somehow join the action then it's just
going to be game over but uh in the
meantime the black king hiding in plain
sight and it definitely feels like these
pawns are kind of double agents white
wants to just give them away
in some circumstances in order to open
up the white rooks
we could see a situation for example of
the pawns okay sacrificing themselves
and just opening things up during out
the black king meanwhile david navarro
at the bar david
i hate it i hate it it says it's winning
for white where's the win wow so okay
white's next move has to be just pushing
this ball up actually this threatens
checkmate in one move so black has to
block now for example if he brings his
bishop out maybe the idea is the same
but black's rook is on the wrong square
this square may be needed as an escape
square for the black king maybe he
should have put his rook here earlier
because now after a check
takes and uh now look at this ivanka
queen takes pawn sacrificing the queen
hitting this bishop as well and if the
bishop gets tempted to take the white
queen
checkmate
i think this is just winner
i think this was missed by david navarro
and this wouldn't be checkmate if this
square was available to the black king
he's blocked in his own king with his
rook and i think white is winning now
jordan he's going to find it surely
after this pawn push next move he's just
going to throw this forward no matter
what
and meanwhile if the black king blocks
then maybe a few different ways for
white but one could be just slowly
bringing the knight back next move
taking this
and delivering a nasty check now the
reason i say this one is because you
want to stop the bishop coming out to
block the diagonal and once again that
rook should have been on the eighth row
because then the piece could have
blockaded that particular square rook
would love to be back uh it's just on
the wrong square and david navarro i
think it's the time and let's go back to
the players because now white pawns
rushing forward navarro scratching his
head he's panicking he's a great
attacker himself navara but one thing i
did notice from studying his games is he
doesn't like to be attacked and uh
phanford is just doing everything this
is beautiful attack from white so far
and still needs finishing touches though
we should say it's still not completely
over yet
you didn't forest he is uh we must say
he's on a roll he won against dingley
ran and he almost won against magnus
carlsen
that was a drawlow and this one now
probably a win for him fantastic is
there still a lot of play left i mean i
only played 24 moves yeah still some um
navarro just needs to now make it as
difficult as possible
for jordan for example force him to find
this beautiful queen sacrifice and going
for this checkmate idea or force him to
do something a bit clever um
personally i've probably blocked this
with my king i just i'm too scared to
allow
white to open up the h file as well as
the g file i just want to block both
pawns
but
it just feels to me this is jordan's
type of position as well he's played to
his strengths in this game and he's also
played against the opponent's weaknesses
but i have to say i was just checking
the computer analysis because i wanted
to see how fine a path does jordan have
to tread in order to find the wind
if you do block the the pawns with your
bishop it's only one way to win and that
is the line that you've highlighted and
he's gone for it he's trying to use his
bishop to cover this diagonal but um the
problem is for white just by process of
an elimination you can get there the one
thing you don't want to do is give black
one more move because black bishop if it
does drop back and blockade these two
white pawns these two white pawns are
never going anywhere and therefore you
can't open up the white rooks so in a
way you have to give up one pawn in
order to open up your rook and look at
jordan just calculating now yeah just
head in his hands trying to work out the
checkmate he's got nearly 10 minutes as
well in a completely winning position
this is where we talk about time saving
it for the important moments yeah well
another clock that is ticking is uh the
auction now less than 30 minutes left 26
minutes left to make your bid for the
tinky winky costume the highest bid 123
dollars you can make a bargain at the
same time as uh supporting unicef's
important work in ukraine so
cctauction.com to make your bid for
tinky winky costume warden now twice by
david howell in this studio
and it would be sad to see it go but uh
it's for a great cause it's right
every penny will go to the unicef yep
and uh yeah so and it's also a moment in
history you know it's not every day that
david howl the legendary english crown
master something yes
where it finds himself in a tinky winky
costume yeah yeah i promise we'll wash
it first you know it's a very warm
costume
oh but it's such a cool costume tinky
winky you guys so
cctauction.com uh 25 minutes left in
that uh auction so go ahead and make
your bid clock is ticking for jordan
from forest but there is no drama on his
clock david namara on the other hand
he's in big trouble on the clock and
more importantly on the board and now it
becomes like a will he won't he find the
solution that david's highlighted it's
the only way to win the game
yeah i'm just taking up the feels so
winning this position so okay a fine
line that white must tread and that
involves starting with queen takes paul
sacrificing the queen
my bad my bad there are two ways to win
a second way is perhaps a little bit
more natural than queen takes ball is
actually just play rook takes bishop
he's found that way um ivanka so he's
actually given up the white rook but
look how he's brought the black king out
of the position um out of its hiding
place and uh white queen now threatening
to step across white's queen joining the
battle on the second rank
that's gonna end in checkmate white
could just swing the queen across
what can black do i think black might
have to at some point give up his queen
by okay there we go checkmate and one
was threatened the queen zooming up to
the top of the board now after a rook
trade white knight is going to deliver a
deadly check a deadly fork and uh
navarro continuing but look at this
that's a fork black's queen is going to
be captured as soon as the black king
moves out of check also the attack
continues black's king is never going to
be safe so material advantage incoming
from van forest and
checkmate possibly on the board white's
queen can now even give a check you
don't even need to go and capture the
black queen yeah you can check on the
diagonal as well so let's force the
black king
back to the very exposed right side of
the board
diagonal checks just remember that
everyone queen end games diagonal checks
tend to be the most effective ah
i don't know why it is it just stops the
enemy king running away um i i've
struggled to find logical explanations
for it but every practical example i
face i even had queen and game recently
diagonal checks now black's king
really struggling to survive but at the
very minimum there's a
simple path of capturing the black queen
with the white knight
and the white queen against the black
rooker knight it should be easy the rook
and knight as well not well placed
at all and uh black's pawn structure is
also in tatters you know if you're
thinking about establishing a fortress
like magnus carlsen had in the last game
forget it look at these pawns none of
them are connected to each other
and there you can see
queen checks and one pawn is going to
drop off
the pawn next to the white queen
captured
okay at least black is trying his best
he's trying to make it complicated by
grabbing the white pawns now but once
the white queen moves out the way
if jordan wants he can just start
grabbing pawns with his king as well the
white king can grab the pawn in front of
it and start marching up the board
to start taking the remaining black
pawns
also it's all about past pawns in these
situations and
after this retreat white's poor now on
the f line can continue marching up and
that black knight is pinned it's ready
to be captured
and okay black's king trying to do a bit
of a dance to dodge this attack but here
we go i think that's the killer blow and
david narrow leans back now the black
knight if it captures the white pawn the
white queen will just slide back one
square and it's a double attack that's a
check and the black knight will fall
on the diagonal yeah
you mentioned it's always the diagonal
it's harder to block the opponent's
pieces simply and the black knight once
it falls that will cost back the game i
think we're about to see a result any
moment
will divert david never resign or will
he continue fighting as ivanka said no
fortress because black's pawns are just
too weak
and
we're waiting for that result it's
hopeless now for black jordan van forest
he really has a very entertaining style
of play and uh this win which is
probably incoming will uh take him to uh
currently third place yeah uh but
navarro not resigning that's good that's
a lesson for everyone at home especially
the younger players you only learn about
endgames you only learn why you're
losing uh by keeping the game going as
long as possible
if i could if i had a dollar for every
playable position i'd resigned uh and
then looked at the computer and said 0.0
i'd be a rich man but uh okay this one
is however hopeless it's just a matter
of time white can start bringing his
king into the game now
the black rook is
not a uh not a sufficient rival for the
white queen and just a bunch of really
interesting results um in this round
vedic has won his game against young
christoph duda so vedic is now currently
in fifth place
fighting his way into the knockout stage
liam as we mentioned he won his game
against uh eric hansen his eighth win so
far this tournament liam
incredible stuff hans nimon an important
win for him against lighting g
niemann had a great first day and is
fighting to qualify all right are we
inching towards that win for jordan yes
the white king can simply step up now uh
white's queen can give as many checks as
as she wants just to annoy the black
king
i'm not sure what else there is to say
unfortunately uh the problem is as soon
as the black pawn starts advancing the
other pawns will drop white's king once
it joins the battle will start kind of
forcing the black king back back back
until the back rank and there will be
checkmating ideas later
um the queen just has too many checks at
its disposal and there we go the king
advances and if black central pawn
matches down with the check the pawn
next to it drops off
so um yeah not too much hope left for
navara he runs away with the king and
now white's king is going to occupy the
central square
there we go blocking the black pawns and
it's a matter of time before the black
pawns start to drop the black rook is
overworked trying to defend everything
all right well as we see a few more
moves in this game kira i wanted to ask
you because i see some questions on
social media as well unicef is obviously
working other places as well not only
ukraine what is happening to the work
in other countries how many other places
is unicef putting up work because of
course people other places in the world
need help as well
we work all over the world yeah and
for the last couple of years we have
worked with the now for the last year we
worked to vaccinate on against the
corvid 19.
because unicef is the largest vaccinator
in the world wow and so unicef is has
taken the role on of bringing out
all the
19 vaccines
on behalf of this
international collaboration called kovax
so
the aim is not to
deliver 2.5 billion vaccines
but it is it is taking time i mean there
are a lot of poor countries where
we still haven't reached more than 10
percent
uh because it is um
logistically very complicated and also
it it's very costly so we also need more
funding into that system yeah so but
slowly slowly that's also uh going going
ahead and that work continues uh even if
a lot of resources now is put into
ukraine and the neighboring countries
yes definitely
but you also have a vaccinations against
polio
so because we we need to to end polio
for good
so we are trying to uh aiming to
vaccinate seven million people in
afghanistan
uh so we have managed to to get started
with that
and polio is a disease that actually has
resurfaced in ukraine wow